[Música]
un submarino nuclear de Estados Unidos
llegó a las aguas de Corea del Sur para
realizar labores de seguridad Marina una
reacción a las recientes demostraciones
armamentísticas de Corea del Norte que
en 2022 realizó al menos unas 50 pruebas
de armas y que busca consolidarse como
una potencia nuclear en el último año
Estados Unidos también aumentó el
despliegue de estratégico en la
Península sobre lo que esto significa
vamos al análisis con la doctora María
del Pilar Álvarez ella es especialista
en política internacional de Corea y del
este de asia Muchas gracias eh María del
Pilar por estar en directo América
Hola buenos días
recientemente Corea del Norte lanzó tres
misiles uno de ellos intercontinental
sumando A los ensayos sin precedentes
del último año en respuesta a esa
movilización Corea del Sur planea
ensayos junto a Estados Unidos en marzo
cada tanto se ven estas acciones de
parte y parte porque la reanudación no
es tan fuerte de la actividad norcoreana
en las últimas semanas y que puede
implicar
bueno Generalmente tenemos un un cambio
que se produce cuando se produce un
cambio político también en Corea del Sur
desde la llegada del nuevo presidente el
presidente y un él es partidario de
afianzar la alianza con los Estados
Unidos y Japón en materia de seguridad
para poder enfrentar lo que se considera
para para el para su partido político y
sus votantes La amenaza permanente de
Corea del Norte esto es un cambio muy
importante respecto del presidente
anterior un y generalmente cuando se
produce en estos cambios y este tipo de
política bueno es como empieza como una
espiral de de violencia y de amenazas
que que va creciendo con el tiempo no
porque a los lanzamientos de Corea del
Norte
empieza a ver estas muestras claras de
una reacción más realista de mayor
seguridad y que no va a haber
concesiones a las amenazas del Norte y
esto genera que el norte entonces haga
amenazas aún más fuertes y bueno y
entramos siempre en unos espirales
bastante bastante complejos y que hay
que ver en este caso Cuál va a ser el
límite No claro Pero además es que se
mantiene en el campo de La retórica no
siempre uno y otro amenaza con que va a
responder más fuertemente ahora en ese
mismo contexto el pentágono dijo que
funcionarios de Estados Unidos y de
Corea del Sur participaron en lo que se
llama un ejercicio de mesa que se centró
en la posibilidad de que Corea del Norte
usara un arma nuclear que seguiría en
ese escenario
Bueno ese es de retórica y de acciones
no Porque estos ejercicios militares y
estas prácticas militares que lleva
adelante Corea del Sur de manera
protocolar como parte de su política de
seguridad pueden hacerse o no como como
bien decías al inicio no con la llegada
sobre todo ahora pusán
de este de este submarino que no que es
una muestra muy clara ahora de un cambio
en la política
pueden llevar o no a hacer más
amenazante las prácticas se hacen se
suelen hacer pero
adquieren distintas connotaciones
detienden justamente también de quién
está en el poder en Corea del Sur el
aumento de las retórica el último caso
que tenemos fue extremadamente negativo
no fue la enorme crisis que se
desarrolló en el 2016 con trampa en el
poder y con otro presidente en Corea del
Sur la presidenta que terminó en una
enorme crisis en materia de seguridad y
en una enorme crisis política también
para Corea del Sur porque tenemos otro
actor más que es china no y que China
tiene su frontera con Corea del Norte es
un afectado directo de todas las
amenazas cruzadas que pueda haber entre
Corea del Norte Estados Unidos y Corea
del Sur y por lo tanto suele también
tomar acciones dependiente de Cuál es el
nivel de cuánto escala el conflicto por
ahora estaríamos como en un inicio
controlable hay que ver cuánto escala
bueno Cuál es el objetivo de Kim Jong al
Buscar ser una potencia nuclear Y a qué
costo ha llegado ese enriquecimiento
armamentístico para el país comunista
bueno la idea de mantenerse como una
potencia nuclear es la estrategia de que
es su única forma de supervivencia no
solo tener armas nucleares ha entendido
por el juego de la política
internacional que es lo único que le da
claramente poder le da la seguridad que
no va a ser este invadida Corea del
Norte y le da estabilidad y el hecho de
que no haya habido hasta ahora ninguna
negociación para la desnuclearización de
Corea del Norte en la cual Corea del
Norte crea que tiene incentivos
materiales reales para llevar adelante
ese programa hace que estemos en la
situación de estancamiento que estamos
ahora es decir de continuar a tantos
años de estar debatiendo políticas de
nuclearización asumir que todas han
fracasado No porque no tiene este
condiciones materiales claras para
llevar adelante ese programa y ahora en
este escenario global parecería Ser aún
menos tentador no con toda la situación
internacional que se está viviendo esto
le da una enorme fuerza para
posicionarse a la hora de negociar para
tener esta diplomacia nuclear para decir
hasta donde llega para tener en una
Corea del Norte que no es la Corea del
Norte de hace 15 o 20 años atrás es una
Corea del Norte Que a pesar de sus
delicadas situación este interna donde
hacer en términos quizás de alimentación
y otras cuestiones de todas maneras ha
mejorado muchísimo su economía
obviamente como un colorario este
indirecto del crecimiento chino entonces
bueno en una Corea del Norte que también
se siente más fuerte que inaugura está
inaugurando ahora todas las semanas
obras obras de edificios que tiene este
autos en las calles para mostrar motos
etcétera no en una Corea del Norte que
se siente mucho más fuerte internamente
bien y ya para el cierre funcionarios de
Estados Unidos y de Corea del Sur han
dicho además que Corea del Norte podría
estar preparándose para su primera
prueba de un dispositivo nuclear esto
desde el año 2017 explica esto la
presencia permanente de Estados Unidos
en la Península ejerciendo este papel
conocido de ser policía del mundo Bueno
en realidad no porque la presencia
permanente de Estados Unidos a la
Península tiene que ver con una
consecuencia de la guerra de Corea justo
este año este se va a cumplir el
aniversario de 70 años de la guerra a
partir del del de la firma del
armisticio entre Corea del Norte y Corea
del Sur como nunca se firmó un acuerdo
de paz que para poder firmar el acuerdo
de paz obviamente lo tiene que motivar a
Estados Unidos porque se firmó a través
de las Naciones Unidas esto nunca se
logró y por lo tanto esto ha justificada
la presencia Estados Unidos en la
Península en Corea del Sur no tiene que
ver con las amenazas actuales no tenemos
una presencia permanente desde 1953 como
un colorario de la guerra de de Corea lo
que provoca estas amenazas si lo
acompaña lo acompaña esta perspectiva
que está ahora en Corea del Sur porque
cambia depende quiere este gobierno de
Corea del Sur es responder a esta
situación de hostilidad que podríamos
decir ya histórica con mostrando un
mayor poder militar es bien realista
mostrando mayor poder militar que el que
pueda tener Corea del Norte pero para su
presencia se justifica desde el fin de
la guerra no es bastante más complejo y
a usar estas amenazas le sirve para
demostrar que bueno que que todavía la
sensación de miedo de un avance posible
justificaría continuar Obviamente con la
ocupación militar de Corea del Sur pues
muchísimas gracias María del Pilar
Álvarez especialista en política
internacionales de Corea y del este de
asia por prestarnos su tiempo para este
análisis que tenga un feliz día
Igualmente gracias por la invitación y a
nuestros televidentes de directo América
quédense con nosotros en pausa de unos
segundos y ya regresamos con más
[Música]